Hallo zusammen, ich bin Stefan von Freewings und ich möchte euch heute etwas erzählen über das Thema Gesetzgebung und das Luftrecht.
Es ist vielleicht ein bisschen ein Angstthema oder ein Thema, das man in der Lernphase auf die Prüfung des SHV vielleicht gerne mal ein bisschen auf die Seite rausschiebt.
Vielleicht auch darum, weil es im Büchlein zu hinterst vorkommt.
Mein Ziel heute ist, um euch ein bisschen die Berührungsangst zu nehmen und euch auch ein bisschen den Praxisbezug von diesem ganzen rechtlichen Teil zu zeigen.
Auf den ersten Blick wirkt es vielleicht nicht ganz so praxisrelevant und spannend wie vielleicht ein Teil wie Meteo- oder Flugpraxis.
Es ist aber trotzdem relativ wichtig, dass man diese Sachen versteht und die Hintergründe kennt,
dass man sicher und jederzeit legal unserem doch relativ verschärften,
verschachtelten Luftraum unterwegs ist.
Genau, es ist ein Lernfach, es ist ganz klar, es gibt viele Paragrafen, die man ein bisschen auswendig lernen muss,
viele Sachen, die im Büchlein stehen, die man nicht gross verstehen muss,
wo es eher darum geht, dass man es büffelt und lernt.
Auf diese Sachen gehe ich jetzt weniger ein in dieser Präsentation.
Mir geht es vor allem um die Sachen, die man in der Hintergrund versteht
und vor allem um die Sachen, die man in der Hintergrund versteht und vor allem um die Sachen, die man in der Hintergrund versteht.
Mir geht es vor allem um den Aufbau der Segelflugkarte und wie diese Lufträume miteinander zusammenspielen
und wie man sie dort zurecht findet.
Weil schlussendlich ist es wie bei vielen Themen so, es ist ganz wichtig, dass ihr wisst, wo nachzuschauen.
Ihr müsst nicht alles auswendig kennen oder die ganze Schweizer Luftraumkarte in- und auswendig kennen.
Ihr müsst einfach wissen, wenn ich in dieses Fluggebiet gehe, muss ich dort,
da und da abklären und nachschauen, dass ihr sicher und mit einem guten Gefühl im Flug starten könnt.
Gut, dann würden wir jetzt gleich anfangen mit den nächsten paar Folien.
Zuerst vielleicht einmal zu der Definition der Hängengleiter.
Wir mit unseren Gleitschirmen sind ja in der Kategorie Hängengleiter
und hier, ganz grob und einfach gesagt, ist die Definition, ein Hängengleiter ist fußstartfähig
und er ist kurz oder unmittelbar nach dem Start, dient er dazu,
um Segelflüge auszuführen, Segel- und Gleitflüge, wie es so schön heisst.
Und das sind ganz unterschiedliche Fluggeräte in dieser Kategorie.
Ihr seht, die Delta sind hier drin, Starflügel, wie man sie in der Mitte sieht,
die schon eher etwas näher an einen Segelflüger oder Flugzeug kommen,
also aerodynamisch gesehen, aber trotzdem immer noch fußstartfähig sind.
Und dann kommen wir mit unseren Gleitschirmen, die auch in dieser Kategorie anzutreffen sind.
Dann kommen wir zu den rechtlichen Grundlagen.
Also der Bund bestimmt oder erlaubt die gesetzlichen Bestimmungen des Schweizer Luftraums.
Die Aufsicht über den ganzen Luftraum hat das BATZL, das Bundesamt für Zivilluftfahrt,
und das BATZL wiederum delegiert die Ausführung über alle die Hängengleiterbestimmungen
am SAV, dem Schweizerischen Hängengleiterverband.
Der SAV kümmert sich vor allem um die Ausbildungen,
um die Prüfungen, um die Zusammenarbeit mit Versicherungsanbietern
für die Dritthaftpflichtversicherung für unseren Sport.
Er kümmert sich um den Wettkampf, um die Jugendförderung,
um verschiedene Fluggebiete, um den Wildschutz, um die Lufträume
und dass das alles ein bisschen harmoniert und uns einen schönen Spielraum ermöglicht,
dass wir unser Hobby in der Schweiz ausführen.
Die Gesetzesbestimmungen sind in der VLK drin.
Da ist die Verordnung über Luftfahrzeuge besonderer Kategorien niedergeschrieben.
In der VLK steht vor allem, wie und wo und wer mit so einem Gleitschirmteuer unterwegs ist.
Da könnt ihr auch gut googlen, da müsst ihr natürlich nicht jeden Paragraph auswendig lernen.
Es ist einfach wichtig, dass ihr wisst, was die VLK ist und was ungefähr dort drin steht
oder um was es geht.
Es sind auch nicht wahnsinnig viele Seiten, es sind etwa drei, vier, vielleicht fünf Seiten,
wo ihr gut durchlesen könnt, ohne dass ihr alles auswendig lernen müsst.
Dann kommen hier weitere Grundlagen.
Ein Hängegleiter, also ein Gleitschirmdelta oder Starflügler wird nicht ins Luftfahrtregister eingetragen.
Das ist speziell in der Luftfahrt, weil sonst die anderen eine Registrierung haben.
Oder auch z.B. im Strassenverkehr muss ja jedes Auto eingetragen sein.
Eine Kennzeichnung muss auf dem Schirm aber angebracht sein.
Das sind Nummern, die jede oder jede Pilotin persönlich vom SAV bekommt und die dann auf dem Schirm anbringen muss.
Da ist es noch wichtig, auch wenn ihr mehrere Schirme habt, diese Nummer ist immer genau die gleiche Nummer auf dem Schirm.
Immer eure persönlich ausgestellte SAV-Nummer.
Die Luftdünftigkeit muss aber von keiner Instanz geprüft werden.
Also es ist nicht wie beim Auto, wo ihr alle zwei Jahre den MFK durchführen müsst.
In anderen Ländern ist es so bei den Gleitschirmen.
In der Schweiz sind wir hier relativ frei.
Oder anders gesagt, es ist sehr viel der Eigenverantwortung oder auch dem gesunden Menschenverstand überlassen.
Vorgeschrieben ist nichts, aber empfohlen ist, dass man einen Schirm alle zwei Jahre checkt.
Zu diesem Thema gehört ihr dann noch mehr in den Material.
Und kommt natürlich ganz darauf an, wie viele Flüge man macht.
Also wenn man sehr, sehr viele Flüge macht, macht vielleicht auch einmal ein Check nach einem kürzeren Intervall Sinn.
Dann zum Notschirm und zum Helm.
Das ist erstaunlicherweise nicht vorgeschrieben, sondern nur bei den Prüfungsflügen im Gesetz verankert,
dass man einen Helm anlegen muss und einen Notschirm dabei haben muss.
Bei Wettkämpfen und anderen Gleitschirmanlässen ist es aber häufig der Fall, dass der Organisator dann vorschreibt.
Einfach aus Sicherheitsgründen, was durchaus auch Sinn macht.
Dann ist es ganz wichtig, dass wir eine Hängengleiterhaftpflichtversicherung haben.
Wir haben die Zusammenarbeit vom Verband mit einer grossen Versicherungsfirma in der Schweiz,
die dann schaut, dass wir mit sehr vielen Teilnehmern eine gute Versicherung abschliessen können.
Weil wenn ihr nämlich einen Unfall habt, seid ihr ja normal über die Unfallversicherung gedeckt,
über den Arbeitgeber oder über die Krankenkasse.
Wenn ihr aber jemandem am Boden oder auch einem Gegenstand am Boden einen Schaden zufügt,
also wenn nach der Landung ein bisschen Zweige kommen zum Beispiel und in ein Auto hineinfliegen,
dann deckt ihr eure Privathaftpflicht nicht.
Und dort ist es dann ganz wichtig, dass ihr so eine Hängengleiterhaftpflichtversicherung abgeschlossen habt.
Das Landen und Starten auf öffentlichen Strassen und auch Scheibpisten ist verboten.
Es ist ganz wichtig, dass man das einhält.
Und was auch erleichtert, dass keine Mindestanzahl vorgesehen ist für Hängengleiterflüge.
Also euer Prövé, wenn ihr es mal habt, läuft in diesem Sinne nicht ab.
Es macht natürlich schon Sinn, dass man viel dran bleibt, viele Routinen gewinnt in diesem Sport.
Oder dass man, wenn man eine längere Pause hatte, auch wieder einen Refresherkurs macht.
Aber gesetzlich ist keine Mindestanzahl an Flügen vorgeschrieben.
Dann ist ja der Schweizer Luftraum recht eng verschachtelt.
Wir sind sehr dicht bewohnt in diesem Land und haben auch einen grossen Luftverkehr.
Aber nebst dem Ganzen, was sich in der Luft abspielt, ist es auch ganz wichtig,
dass man am Boden gewisse Regeln einhält.
Und da möchte ich v.a. auf alle die eidgenössischen Schutzgebiete und kantonale Wildruhezonen hinweisen.
Es gibt auch private Schutzgebiete sowie viele lokale Vereinbarungen mit Wildhütern und Jägern.
Einen grossen Teil davon findet ihr auf dieser Seite, auf map.go.admin.ch,
wo ihr dann auch die verschiedenen Wildruhezonen findet.
Wo ihr dann auch die verschiedenen Wildruhezonen findet.
Hier könnt ihr z.B. die Jagdbahngebiete rausfiltern.
Und wenn ihr draufklickt, seht ihr, dass sie von wann bis wann aktiv sind.
So können wir das Wild und die Natur möglichst schonen und damit schützen, dass wir unseren Sport schützen können.
Damit wir uns hier nicht etwas zu fest rein falschen gehen sollen.
Das ist ein sehr wichtiges Thema, das auch beim SAV auf der Homepage vorgelegt wird.
thematisiert wird unter Flutgebiet Wildschutz.
Wenn ihr dort reingeht, könnt ihr auch Hängegleiten und Wildtiere
das Dokument als PDF herunterladen.
Es ist sehr interessant zu sehen, welche Arten wo bedroht sind
und auf was man achten sollte und auch zu welcher Jahreszeit.
Also kann ich es wärmstens empfehlen, um hier einen Blick hineinzuwerfen.
Wir werden uns jetzt aber vor allem auf den Luftraumteilen in dieser Präsentation beschränken.
Somit geht es gleich weiter mit dem Vortritt.
In der Luftfahrt ist immer Rechtsvortritt.
Es ist ganz ähnlich wie im Strassenverkehr.
Der oder die Pilotin, die von rechts kommt, hat Vortritt.
Nur im ganz grossen Unterschied zum Strassenverkehr
können wir nicht einfach anhalten oder Pause drücken.
Wenn wir uns nahe kommen, müssen wir schnell handeln,
obwohl der Gleitschirm ja noch eines der
Fluggeräte ist, das sehr langsam fliegt,
müssen wir trotzdem das Motto «Sehen und gesehen werden»
also wirklich vorausschauen,
probieren zu antizipieren, was vielleicht die anderen in der Luft
für Absichten haben könnten, wo sie vielleicht durchfliegen möchten
und dass man so eigentlich schon anfängt auszuweichen,
bevor es überhaupt eng wird
oder bevor man überhaupt vor dieser Entscheidung steht,
hey, wer hat jetzt Vortritt.
Also eigentlich ist das Ziel, schon vorher zu reagieren,
dass man gerne in so eine Situation reinkommt, wo es eng wird.
Der Abstand ist nämlich auch nicht definiert.
Der wird einfach als genügend Sicherheitsabstand bezeichnet.
Auch hier wieder gesunder Menschenverstand.
Lieber einmal etwas mehr Abstand halten als zu wenig.
Lieber einmal eine Landung etwas zu kurz kommen oder etwas ausweichen
und auf einer Weise nebenan landen, wenn es irgendwie eng wird.
Zum Thema Randwirbel und wie es ist, wenn man zu nah aufeinander auffliegt,
gehört dann auch noch im Teil Flugpraxis oder Aerodynamik.
Genau.
Das Überholen im freien Luftraum ist erlaubt.
Am Hang ist es verboten.
Zu den Hangvortrittsregeln kommen wir gleich noch in den nächsten Folien.
Im Thermikschlauch auch immer wieder eine Situation,
die man im Fliegeralltag erlebt,
dass man in den Thermikschlauch hineinfliegt
und sich dann bewusst sein muss, in welche Richtung man dreht.
Und das ist nämlich noch ganz interessant.
Es ist nicht der unterste oder die oberste Pilotin, die sagt, wo es durchgeht,
sondern der Schirm, der als erstes in diesem Schlauch ist,
gibt die Drehrichtung an.
Also auch wenn ihr höher hineinfliegt als jemand anderes,
wenn der da unten links dreht, müsst ihr auch links drehen,
weil es kann ja sein, dass der oder die unter euch ein bisschen besser fliegt,
einen besseren Schirm hat,
der einfach schöner in der Thermik ist und euch einholt.
Und wenn ihr dann nämlich auf der gleichen Höhe seid und gegengleich dreht,
dann habt ihr, wenn ihr aufeinander zukommt,
eine recht hohe Geschwindigkeitsdifferenz,
die dann auch wieder gefährlich sein könnte.
Darum immer ganz wichtig, im gleichen Uhrzeigersinn zu drehen.
Und interessant ist auch noch, achtet darauf,
dass ihr auch bei den Vögeln im gleichen Kreis dreht
oder im gleichen Uhrzeigersinn.
Das klingt vielleicht lustig, aber auch die Vögel,
die haben sich in unserem Breitengrad,
weil das Gleitschirmfliegen ja sehr verbreitet ist,
an uns gewöhnt und die drehen ganz friedlich in den meisten Fällen mit uns mit.
Aber wenn wir natürlich anfangen, dagegen zu drehen,
dann verschrecken die auch.
Im tiefsten Fall verscheuchen wir es irgendwie weg von ihrem Heimgebiet,
was ja sicher gerne nicht gut wäre.
Darum auch dort, klingt vielleicht lustig,
aber schaut auch, dass ihr bei den Vögeln im gleichen Uhrzeigersinn dreht.
Und meistens fliegen sie sowieso viel besser als wir
und überhöhen uns dann ziemlich schnell.
Dann kommen wir zu der Vortrittsregel am Hang.
Auch hier wieder, wenn wir frontal aufeinander zufliegen,
weichen wir ja rechts aus.
Nicht nur, wenn wir 90 Grad aufeinander zufliegen,
sondern auch frontal immer rechts ausweichen.
Am Hang ist es dann so, dass ja jemand von diesen beiden Schirmen
nach rechts wirklich keine Optionen hat
oder nicht gross ausweichen kann.
Auch hier wieder ist es natürlich schön,
wenn jetzt der grüne Schirm rücksichtsvoll fliegt
und schon früh anfängt auszuweichen
und nicht erst in den letzten paar Metern,
weil natürlich der Hangaufwind vielmals näher am Hang besser ist.
Auch hier, ja, schaut aufeinander,
weichet doch frühzeitig aus,
gebt frühzeitig ein Zeichen, also wegdreht vom Hang,
dass der andere Schirm weiss, hey, er hat mich gesehen
und er lässt mir Platz zum Vorbeifliegen.
Und vielmals ist der Aufwind ganz nah am Hang
auch nicht einmal unbedingt besser als etwas weiter weg.
Genau, so kommen wir dann schön aneinander vorbei.
Dann ist noch die Definition vom Überholen.
Das ist jetzt sehr theoretisch
und auch sehr auf den rechtlichen Teil bezogen,
aber im Büchlein ist es beschrieben.
Und ich habe es schon vielmals erlebt,
dass Flugschüler mich gefragt haben,
weil sie ein wenig verwirrt waren von dieser Erklärung oder der Darstellung.
Hier geht es eigentlich vor allem darum,
zu unterscheiden, was zählt als Überholen
und was zählt als einfach kreuzen
oder sich von rechts annähern.
Und hier wird es beschrieben mit diesem Winkel von diesen 70 Grad,
also 2 mal 70 wären dann die 140 Grad gegen hinten.
Alles, was sich von hinten annähert, zählt als Überholen.
Wenn ihr aber vor dieser 70-Grad-Linie seid,
also der Blaue hat jetzt eigentlich Vortritt gegenüber dem Grünen,
weil er kommt von rechts.
Aber der Rote unten links hat keinen Vortritt,
weil er ist der, der überholt.
Und der, der überholt, hat nie Vortritt.
Also immer der Überholte hat Vortritt.
Weil er sieht ja gerne, was hinter ihm passiert.
Genau.
Wiederum, in der Praxis passiert es eher weniger,
weil man eben im Idealfall schon weit voraus
dieser Situation versucht, aus dem Weg zu gehen.
Und auf jeden Fall nicht versucht, einen Vortritt zu erzwingen.
Dann weitere Vortrittsregeln.
Es brennen die Flugzeuge oben links
oder anders gesagt einfach ein Flugzeug
oder ein Luftfahrzeug,
das sich im Notfall befindet,
hat am meisten Vortritt,
weil er nicht mehr gut manövrieren kann.
Und diese Fluggeräte,
also der Helikopter oder der Motorflieger zum Beispiel,
die am manövrierfähigsten sind,
die haben keinen Vortritt.
Also die müssen ausweichen.
Und so geht eigentlich das Stegeli dann schön runter.
Das Zweite wären die Ballone.
Die können logischerweise auch nicht so gut ausweichen.
Nachher, das ist noch interessant,
kommen Gleitschirme und Zegelflieger.
Wir sind hier in der gleichen Kategorie,
weil ein Zegelflieger viel schneller unterwegs ist
als ein Gleitschirm.
Aber vortrittsrechtstechnisch sind wir hier
in der gleichen Kategorie.
Nachher kommen die Zeppelin,
wo wir Vortritt haben gegenüber den Zeppelin.
Nachher kommen die schleppenden Motorfahrzeuge,
weil auch die sind relativ gut manövrierfähig.
Und am Schluss noch Flugzeuge und Helikopter.
So, jetzt kommen wir zum Hauptteil
dieser ganzen Präsentation.
Und zwar ist das die Zegelflugkarte.
Wieso braucht es überhaupt eine Zegelflugkarte?
Oder was ist eine Zegelflugkarte?
Wie es der Name schon sagt,
ist sie vor allem für Zegelflugzeuge und Hängegleiter.
In der Zegelflugkarte sind Luftraumklassen,
Gefahren, Flugbeschränkungsgebiete, Hindernisse,
Zegelflugzonen für uns,
also die LSR for Gliders heissen die neu,
die sind für uns als Gleitschirmpiloten
und auch für die Zegelflüger hier.
Was das genau beinhaltet,
zu dem kommen wir dann gleich noch.
Und auch die militärischen Flugdienstzeiten.
Und nochmal schnell zum Wieso.
Es ist natürlich ganz, ganz wichtig,
wie gesagt, in der Schweiz ist der Luftraum
relativ eng verschachtelt und relativ komplex.
Und darum ist es ganz wichtig,
dass wir uns auch an diese Lufträume halten
und nur dort fliegen, wo wir auch hören
und uns gut informieren.
Weil es hat durchaus schon Fehler gegeben,
wo Gleitschirme in der Thermik so hoch hochgestiegen sind,
dass sie eben in eine Anflugschneise
reingekommen sind von einem Flughafen.
Das ist schon mehrmals passiert.
Das ist jetzt nur ein Beispiel.
Und es ist natürlich in erster Linie
einfach extrem gefährlich.
Meistens kann man dann schon noch reagieren,
im Idealfall.
Was aber zu verspätigen und extremen Kosten führt.
Und der Dreipunkt ist einfach auch noch,
es ist wahnsinnig schlecht für unser Image,
wenn natürlich dann das zu vielmals vorkommt
in der Nähe von Flughafen.
Dann heisst es dann einfach,
gut, in diesem Fall verbieten wir das Gleitschirmfliegen
ganz verboten in dieser Umgebung.
Und in der Schweiz, wo wir recht viele Flugplätze haben,
kleine und auch grosse,
würde das schon bedeuten,
dass dann recht viele Fluggebiete gefördert sind.
Darum ist es ganz, ganz wichtig,
dass man hier im legalen Bereich unterwegs ist.
Die Segelflugkarte könnt ihr googlen
und dann ist es der map.geo.admin.ch-Link,
den ihr öffnen könnt.
Dort ist die elektronische, digitale Karte,
wo ihr auch eine Legende dazu öffnen könnt als PDF,
wo dann auch alle die Tags und die Symbole beschrieben sind.
Ich finde es persönlich auch noch gut,
wenn man eine physische Karte in der Hand hat.
Es gibt einem einfach so ein bisschen den Überblick.
Man kann es ein bisschen besser zuordnen.
Man darf sich einfach nicht allzu fest beeindrucken lassen,
weil auf den ersten Blick sieht es natürlich
extrem beeindruckend aus oder auch komplex aus.
Aber das Gute ist ja,
dass man meistens in dem Fluggebiet,
in dem man fliegt,
und wenn man da mal ein bisschen hineinzoomt,
dass es dann eben gar nicht so schlimm ist,
wie jetzt, wenn man die ganze Schweiz
als ganze Saison anschaut.
Immer im März kommt die neue Ausführung heraus,
die man dann kaufen kann.
Ich mache es jetzt so,
ich kaufe nicht jedes Jahr die neueste.
Ich habe einfach eine,
die ich dann zwei, drei Jahre habe,
einfach so ein bisschen für den Überblick.
Und bevor ich dann aber in die Luft gehe,
gehe ich sowieso immer noch mal online schauen,
weil dann habe ich den aktuellsten Stand.
Dann kommen wir jetzt zu ein paar Abkürzungen,
die ihr jetzt im Verlauf der Präsentation
immer wieder ein bisschen hören werdet.
Auch im Zusammenhang mit der Segelflugkarte.
Die Abkürzung GLDK ist die Segelflugkarte,
die Glider Chart,
die wir jetzt kurz besprochen haben
und nachher noch genauer anschauen.
Das AIP ist das Luftfahrtenhandbuch.
Dort haben wir allgemein gültige Informationen
für alle Benutzer des Schweizer Luftraums.
Dann haben wir das NOTAM.
Das ist eine täglich publizierte Informationsquelle
für Luftfahrer,
wo Lufträume, Restriktionen
und auch Gefahren und Hindernisse
am Boden eingezeichnet sind.
Und das DABS,
das Daily Airspace Bulletin Switzerland,
da ist eigentlich,
neben der Segelflugkarte,
das Hauptinstrument,
das ich anschaue,
bevor ich in die Luft gehe.
Weil im DABS wird auch täglich publiziert,
welche Lufträume momentan aktiv sind
und wo wir nicht da hineinfliegen.
Zu dem kommen wir aber auch gleich noch später
zu einem Praxisbeispiel.
Dann haben wir hier ganz viele Abkürzungen,
die ich euch gerade empfehlen würde.
Macht doch ein Foto oder ein Screenshot.
Da kommen immer wieder einmal die Abkürzungen vor.
Ganz wichtig, wenn es um die Höhe geht,
ist immer gut, wenn man schnell schaut,
ist es über Grund oder ist es über Meer.
Das ist nämlich ganz wichtig,
dass keine Fehler passieren.
Dann VFR, VFR ist Visual Flight Rules,
also Sichtflugregeln.
Und das ist eigentlich der Bereich,
in den wir uns mit dem Gleitschirm bewegen.
IFR, also Instrument Flight Rules,
da gehen nur Flugzeuge hinein,
die auch richtig ausgerüstet sind.
Für den Instrumentenflug.
Und auch nur Piloten und Pilotinnen,
die die nötige Lizenz dafür haben.
Und wir mit dem Gleitschirm,
egal wie viel GPS und wie viele Instrumente
wir vorne uns draufklettern,
können nicht nach Instrumentenflugregeln fliegen
und auch nicht in die Wolke hineinfliegen.
Zu dem kommen wir dann auch noch.
Aber ganz wichtig zu merken,
uns mit dem Gleitschirm betrifft nur das VFR.
Dann kommen wir später auch noch
zu den Flight Levels,
die Flugflächen und was das alles genau beinhaltet.
Die drei Bezeichnungen CTR, TMA und AWI
sind meistens oder nein,
immer in der Nähe von Flughäfen.
Also CTR erstreckt sich immer vom Boden
bis zu einer bestimmten Höhe.
Die TMA sind quasi die Anflugschneisen
von Start und Landung.
Und die Airways sind die längeren Lufträume,
die grosse Hauptverbindungsströme,
die die Strecke und die Verbindungen
der Flughafen zusammenführen.
Zu dem kommen wir später noch dazu.
Die Lufträume haben immer einen Namen.
In der Schweiz fängt man meistens mit LS an.
Das L steht für Lower Europe
und das S steht für Switzerland.
Zum Beispiel LSZR wäre jetzt Altery.
Da kommen hinten noch zwei Buchschreiben dazu,
die dann hier zugeteilt sind.
LSZH wäre Zürich und dann gibt es auch noch
die Restricted Areas und so weiter.
Zu dem kommen wir später noch.
Dann hat es auf der ganzen Welt
sieben verschiedene Luftraumklassen.
Die sind von der ICAO,
der Internationalen Zivilluftfahrtsorganisation,
einmal bestimmen worden.
In der Schweiz kommen aber nur vier zur Anwendung.
Das ist das G und das E.
Die sind frei.
Das heisst, man darf dort hineinfliegen.
Das C und das D sind nur mit Freigabe
und Flugfunk erlaubt, um hineinfliegen zu können.
Das heisst, wenn man irgendwo,
kommt es vielleicht einmal vor,
wenn wir auf einem langen Streckenflug sind,
dass man irgendwo knapp in eine Anflugschneise kämpft.
Dann haben wir die Möglichkeit,
um anzufunken und unter ständigem Funkkontakt
können wir dann vielleicht auch
diese Anflugschneise durchqueren.
Das ist aber natürlich nicht garantiert.
Das ist also nur mit Freigabe und ständigem Funkkontakt.
Nur beim E und beim G können wir immer hineinfliegen.